[Musique]
peut-être y at-il parmi vous des gens
qui ont fait l'expérience éventuellement
douloureuse de la rupture amoureuse
après une rupture il arrive qu'on se
remette en question mais il arrive aussi
qu'on change rien à sa vie en continuant
comme avant dans tous les cas c'est un
moment qui est si brutale radical qu'il
nous permet d'apercevoir quelques-uns de
nos paradoxes alors par paradox je veux
pas parler de toutes petites choses
par exemple nous en serons prêts un
copain qui vous invite à l'apéro alors
vous lui demandez qu'est ce que
j'apporte et lui va vous répondra en
rien du tout penses tu
c'est la bonne franquette j'ai tout ce
qu'il faut à la maison alors en dépit de
ce que vous venez de vous dire les
usages sociaux font que vous avez
compris vous alliez à me porter quelque
chose est votre ami s'attend à ce que
vous apportez quelque chose alors si un
extraterrestre venu de la planète
premier degré était témoin de tout ça il
se dirait que vraiment les protocoles
sociaux des humains sont vraiment
bizarre alors je vais parler de
paradoxes qui sont pas beaucoup plus
complexe mais qui ont un impact plus
important sur l'existence parce que ça
se passe dans le cadre d'une rupture
faut que je vous parle de jessica
jessica c'est une copine à moi puis
s'est fait larguer un certain nombre de
fois et qui me racontait qu'elle en
avait vraiment marre de tomber sur des
connards encore des connards toujours
des connards alors moi j'insiste un
petit peu impuissant ou déconvenues
amoureuses de jessica alors premier
connard pas de bol deuxième connard
vraiment pas de bol mais au 10e connard
c'est quand même difficile de ne pas
trouver qui est un genre de schéma qui
s'installe bon le le paradoxe si on
devait le représenter sur une carte
routière
ce serait l'embranchement de la route
qui mène au déni et de la route qui mène
à la remise en question alors à propos
de questions je vous en pause et une est
ce que vous connaissez le point commun
qu'il ya entre les chatouilles et les
crottes de nez le point commun qui entre
les chatouilles et les crottes de nez
mais le point commun c'est que c'est une
question de point de vue
si vous prenez la personne la plus chère
to use du monde et vous lui demander de
se chatouiller elle-même vous avez pas
obtenir grand chose alors peut-être que
parmi vous il ya encore des gens qui
mangent leurs crottes de nez mais en
tout cas quand vous étiez petit au pic
de votre consommation de crottes de nez
si on vous avait proposé les crottes de
nez de quelqu'un d'autre vous en auriez
jamais voulu parce que là encore c'est
une question de point de vue revenons à
jessica
si pour vous et pour moi c'est facile de
mettre le doigt sur son paradoxe
pour elles c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
et surtout on peut pas le faire à sa
place
alors peut-être qu'à ce stade il y en a
quelques-uns d'entre vous qui se disent
bon je suis pas très psychologue tout ça
ça me passe au dessus de la cafetière
il faut que je me présente j'ai 42 ans
et si vous m'aviez dit quand j'étais
petit quinze jours j'ai créé un livre de
psychologie de couple non seulement je
vous aurais pas cru
et en plus vous aurez carrément rayonner
je viens d'un environnement extrêmement
cartésien j'ai fais maths sup maths spé
je pense que quand j'étais plus jeune
j'ai dû dire à ma compagne de l'école de
l'époque aurait dit non c'est pas un
petit peu dans ta tête tout ça pour moi
cette époque là la psychologie c'était
comme la décoration d'intérieur un truc
de filles
sauf que quand j'ai divorcé il a bien
fallu que je me bats mon appartement bon
alors j'ai fait très simple j'ai été au
plus plus rapide et j'ai fait
fonctionnel j'ai été dans un magasin
d'ameublement suédois j'ai assez à
acheter un certain nombre de trucs et
rapidement s'est posé la question des
rideaux alors les rideaux je vais je me
suis dit je vais le prendre blanc depuis
pas cher sauf que des rideaux blancs et
pas cher il ya quatre modèles différents
alors est ce que j'en ai six rien à
faire que ça de la décoration
d'intérieur
au point de prendre le premier qui se
présente sans réfléchir ou est-ce que je
vais quand même prendre cinq minutes
pour choisir celui qui vous plaît le
plus et c'est comme ça mesdames
messieurs que je suis tombé dans une
drogue dure
la décoration d'intérieur alors le
paradoxe six loges dans des toutes
petites choses comme vous le voyez ça
peut se loger dans quatre rideaux blancs
au même prix donc le paradoxe est pas
très orgueilleux et en plus de ça le
paradoxe est taquin bon je vous dis
tout à l'heure le paradoxe et
l'embranchement de la route qui mène
soit ou des niçois la remise en question
et c'est certain que dans cette salle il
ya des gens qui sont dans le déni si je
voulais faire une expérience et que j'ai
demandé à ce qu'on rallume la salle et
que demandait aux gens qu'ils pensent
être dans le déni de lever la main on
assisterait à un autre paradoxe
quelqu'un qui a suffisamment de lucidité
pour dire qu'il est dans le déni ne
l'est assurément pas le paradoxe est
décidément blagueur donc le comprenez
moi bien moi j'ai pas du tout en train
de dire que hors de la remise en
question point de salut et que le déni
c'est vraiment pour les gros nuls le
déni c'est éminemment fonctionnel le
déni c'est cette construction
intellectuelle qui permet à votre
cerveau de se préserver quand vous avez
le principe de réalité qui arrive à fond
la caisse vers vous en emportant tout
sur son passage
si on revient à jessica qu'est-ce qui
est le plus facile pour elle de se dire
en dépit du mal que ça me fait je
persiste à me remettre avec des connards
et ça dit beaucoup de choses sur moi et
sur comment je fonctionne
ou alors est-ce que c'est plus facile
pour être de dire moi c'est les mecs qui
sont tous des connards où j'ai rien à
voir là dedans alors passons à des
travaux pratiques
je vous reposer notre question à votre
avis pourquoi les hommes piste de boue
c'est une question simple pourquoi les
hommes piste de goût je vous vois
perplexe je vous proposais de réponse
réponse à les hommes puissent debout
parce que c'est une marque de leur
virilité
c'est un atavisme de de l'époque où il
fallait être sur le qui vive tout le
temps prêt à se défendre à n'importe
quel moment au dessus vous imaginez pas
toutes les discussions franches et
viriles qu'il ya dans des toilettes
hommes dans des urinoirs réponse à ou
alors réponse b si les hommes puissent
debout c'est parce que c'est pas eux qui
nettoie alors peut-être que dans l'une
de ces deux réponses
je vous laisse juge vous avez détecté
une part de dénis je vous donne un
indice
on reconnaît souvent le déni parce que
il passe par un certain nombre
d'explications alambiquées
alors que la vérité est beaucoup plus
simple donc le déni et blagueur le
dernier pas très orgueilleux et stages
dans des petites choses mais surtout le
déni ne vous posera jamais la question
de votre permission
si vous voulez vous en convaincre vous
avez qu'à penser à la pornographie la
pornographie c'est quelque chose qui est
câblé pour parler directement à votre
inconscient la pornographie c'est comme
élise lucet vous l'avez pas invité elle
est venue quand même et elle vous pose
des tas de questions vous avez
absolument pas envie d'entendre
alors vous pouvez penser ce que vous
voulez de l'homosexualité des plans à
trois quatre cinq du fétichisme du pied
mais si vous êtes exposés à une forme de
pornographie que votre cerveau rejette
en bloc mais à laquelle votre le reste
de votre organisme sautent de joie à
l'idée de faire un tour de manège
vous êtes bien obligé de vous poser la
question bonjour 1 élise lucet cash
investigations alors dites moi c'est
quoi cette petite érection
le paradoxe vous posera jamais la
question et ne vous demandera jamais la
permission et en plus de ça le paradoxe
est patient et reviendra à la charge
autant fois qu'il faut le paradoxe c'est
comme le méchant dans un film d'horreur
tant que vous voudrez sais pas au milieu
enfin en travers de son chemin et que
vous lui tendez pas le coup il va
revenir encore et encore et encore
jessica contre les connards 2 la
vengeance
jessica contre les connards 3 il revient
et il n'est pas content vous ne pouvez
pas échapper à vos paradoxe c'est pour
ça qu'un jour si quelqu'un vous fais la
remarque suivante et vous dit c'est
quand même pas à l'abri de tes
contradictions
vous pouvez vous en féliciter jean
cocteau disait ce que le public te
reproche cultive le sétois
alors même si vos paradoxe ne vont pas
sans une certaine dose de perplexité
embrasser les chéris scellé il n'est pas
impossible qu en chemin vous vous
découvriez vous même
[Musique]